i want to thank you all for joining me
in our fantastic speaker today i have
professor mike snyder with me
mike snyder is the stanford asherman
professor and chair of genetics and the
director
of the center for genomics and
personalized medicine at stanford
university school of medicine
he's a leader in the field of functional
genomics and proteomics
and one of the major participants of the
encode project
his laboratory study was the first to
perform a large-scale functional
genomics project
in any organism and has launched many
technologies in genomics and proteomics
that have been used
for characterizing genomes proteomes and
regulatory networks
dr snyder received his phd training at
the california institute of technology
and carried out post-doctoral training
at stanford university
thank you all for being here and i'll
now pass it over to professor snyder
great well thanks very much jackie it's
terrific to be here
and i look forward to sharing with you
what we're up to
and what's going on in the field of
virus detection and
vaccine development and i think all of
you know this is an incredibly hot
area right now one very pertinent to the
current pandemic
so what i want to do for this talk is go
over what's going on and covet 19
sars2 background there give you a little
background information
then i'll talk about what's happening
now in terms of infection detection
and new technologies that are coming out
in this area and then finally i'd like
to tell you about
vaccine development and what's emerging
in that area
so um by way of background just
i'm sure all of you know probably a lot
of what i'll tell you already but
covered 19
is a disease and it's caused by the sars
kb2
chronovirus chronoviruses are common
colds but the
sars kobe 2 obviously is fairly special
it first appeared in wuhan china
it definitely has originated in bats and
what's not so clear is whether it went
through an intermediate species before
it transferred over to humans
or it went over to humans and evolved a
bit before
becoming its current form it's very
different oh sorry it's obviously
a huge problem these days uh even though
we're
finally going on the down swing a little
bit there's still over 140 000
new cases every day so that we're still
in the midst of an
incredibly important pandemic and i
think most people will agree this virus
is here to stay
and so how we're going to deal with it
how we're going to detect it how we're
going to
you know defend ourselves against it is
a hugely important topic
so what's special about uh sarge kov2
and and cod19 is that it's very
different from most
uh viruses most common colds they
actually
infect the upper respiratory system but
occasionally a very severe strain comes
along like
sarge you may recall two decades ago or
bird flu
they penetrate deep into the lungs and
that's why they cause severe problems
and
kill people so tsar's kobe 2 can do both
that can be
sometimes hang out in the upper
respiratory pathway but also it can
penetrate deep
into lungs in many cases and so that's
what makes it
particularly problematic it's also
problematic in the sense that
it can spread asymptomatically and and
there's a number of studies out there
they're a bit all over the place
but i think the consensus is emerging
that somewhere around the order of about
40 to 45 percent of
of infections are asymptomatic meaning
the individuals
never get symptoms and so they can
potentially be spreading this virus
without even knowing it and of course
that's a huge problem
since that then can let this thing
become incredibly widespread
what why is the sars curvy 2 so special
well it has two
kinds of changes that are very different
from
the regular common cold chronovirus and
they both occur
in this protein called the spike protein
so this is a protein that sits on the
surface of the virus
and as i say it has two very significant
changes that are out there
one change actually affects what's
called the receptor binding site
so there's a change in there that makes
it much more high affinity so it'll bind
what's called the ac2 receptor on our
cells
and therefore help it penetrate
and the other thing is there's a
cleavage site in the spike protein
that's important for
propagation of the virus if you will and
basically what's happened is there's
been some genetic changes
in this region both these are found in
the bat actually
uh or evolved from the bat and so what's
happened is these cleavage sites
uh allow much much more efficient
cleavage these changes that have
appeared but they actually use a human
enzyme
to cleave them and so now what happens
is this virus can spread very very
efficiently in humans
very differently from the original
common cold coronavirus
that's out there what's also concerning
these days is that there's at least
three major variants out there that are
attracting people's attention
one is this uk strain you may have heard
of its features are it's very fast
spreading
thought to be at least 40 percent more
transmissible
it doesn't seem to be a problem from the
vaccine standpoint that is when you get
vaccinated you still make antibodies
that neutralize it
uh but there is some very very recent
evidence that says it might be 30
percent
uh more lethal there's also a south
african strain that's
now coming to the u.s it has a six-fold
reduction this is why it's concerning
six-fold reduction
in protection from neutralizing
antibodies
and so people are worried it's partially
resistant to vaccine
and then the third strain that's also
emerges this brazil strain if you will
it also seems to spread very rapidly
and it may have also reduced response
and neutralizing antibodies so the
concern is that some of these strains
may actually get around some of our
vaccinations and make them less
effective
but um they are certainly emerging there
there's no question
that some of these strains like the uk
and brazil one will take over they're
just moving very very quickly
some people estimate as quickly as six
weeks they'll become the dominant strain
in the u.s
and they're already in many many
different states if not all
so how do we detect these viruses well
there are several major approaches that
are out there
the gold standard is this one uh the pcr
test
and there's another one these two tests
pcr and
antigen tests detect active infections
so the pcr
test involves i won't get through the
details you can learn about more of this
if you take our certificate program
but you you actually what you'll do is
you'll you'll have a probe
to the nucleic acid part of the virus
it's called the the rna part
and you can amplify that you actually
take a nasal swab
and then you collect a little bit
actually on a simple q-tip if you will
and then you have um you can amplify the
virus and you have very specific
sequences they can detect it's very very
sensitive assay the antigen test doesn't
really go after the mr or the
the rna part of the virus it really
detects the protein part the part that's
typically on the surface
and so what you'll do there is your same
thing you'll have a nasal swab
you can do something called an elisa
assay it's a very simple very common
assay that
a lot of diagnostic companies use we
have antibodies that will recognize the
protein
and you can also tell this is occurring
now both these assays they actually
don't turn
positive if you get infected you won't
be positive until about three days later
three to four days later
according to most estimates and so there
is a lag phase
but nonetheless this one when if you do
catch it at that time it's quite
sensitive it works
in the vast majority of cases it's false
positive rates fairly low typically
one to three percent for the antigen
test uh
um it's not quite as sensitive
and it's false positive rates probably
similar maybe a little bit higher
but both these are are the tests that
are commonly used i'll come back to
what their advantage is disadvantage in
a minute there's another kind of test
that's out there it's an antibody test
and so if you've ever been infected by a
virus what will happen is you will make
antibodies to it they protect you
and they hang around for a long time in
your blood so what you can do there
is simply draw blood from a person and
run a test if you have
uh you can see if you have antibodies
against the virus by having some of the
common proteins
again set up in a nice little assay and
you can
again detect whether you've had
antibodies so the advantage of this is
you can tell
if you've ever been infected by a virus
certainly within the last six months or
a year
you can tell from the antibody test but
it won't tell you if you have an
active infection in contrast these these
do
so now the pros and cons then again
the pcr test is very sensitive it's the
one most people use when you go get
tested
the problem is it takes 24 to 48 hours
to get back your result
the antigen test is is probably less
sensitive it is less sensitive but you
get your result back in 15 minutes very
convenient and it's actually
a bit cheaper and finally the antibody
test is a very different kind of test it
tells you whether you've ever been
infected
in the past it won't tell you if you're
infected now
what's kind of nice is that these are
becoming more convenient so these days
you can usually get a pcr test
by being able to pick up the kit ahead
of time there's a number of kits that
are out there
you actually can do the nasal swab at
home and you simply drop them in a
mailbox or a drop-off site
and then they'll mail you back your
results in 24 to 48 hours
there's also these are very newly
emerging some at-home tests that are
coming these are
not so expensive the range varies a bit
um
yeah they're ranging people estimate
around thirty dollars so it can be more
uh again they can be done in 15 minutes
this particular one is approved for
for a two-year-olds and higher i think
this one might be 14 years
old and higher so the point is that you
can actually do these a simple home test
kind of like a pregnancy test you can
see right on the spot
if you've got a positive result they're
they're not as accurate just to warn you
uh as what you'll do for a gold standard
test but nonetheless they're very
convenient
and it's better to get tested uh than
not at all
and so it's thought that the sensitivity
of these is on the order of about 40
or so but you can do them many times
uh here is also there's recently emerged
a very new pcr at home test
this one takes 30 minutes and it's not
too bad overall
okay so so that's what's going on right
now for testing
again becoming more and more common but
there's a new kind of technology that's
emerging out there
that we think is going to be powerful
this is an area that we work on that
we're trying to revolutionize
and this is using wearable sensors so
you may know that
smart watches and other sensors are worn
by millions of people
in fact 21 50 million people in the us
alone wear a smart watch what's powerful
about them is they'll make hundreds of
thousands of measurements on you
every day they follow you 24 7. so
they're always following your physiology
and in fact they can measure many many
different kinds of things they can
measure your heart rate
something called heart rate variability
respiration even blood oxygen
can be measured skin temperature can be
reasonably accurate
and blood pressure and so on so it
depends on the devices different devices
measure different things
and they measure them with different
accuracies of resolution
but they are quite powerful
and so uh the way we got into this
business by all uh
somewhat interestingly is because i
actually discovered my lyme disease
using a smart watch and something called
a pulse ox
and so i won't get into the story in too
much detail but
the bottom line was uh um i had been i
discovered my my heart rate was
abnormally low for my smart watch and my
blood oxygen was no for my pulse ox
and later i learned my skin temperature
was off as well
and so uh it turns out that and it was
due to lyme disease that
told me it's i was being infected by
lyme before i had symptoms even
and so i talked to a doctor he actually
told me recommended penicillin i said no
i need
doxycycline it's a little bit tense he
gave in
and sure enough i got tested i was lying
positive it's very well controlled
experiment
but anyway that prompted us i'd been
wearing a watch for two years we went
back and looked at
every single time i had a high heart
rate
i can't see that but that's on the
x-axis
or high skin temperature and it turns
out there were four
times when i had high heart rate skin
temperature and every single one of
those i had high
what's called a high biomarker for being
ill
so one was the lime time i told you
about that's these triangle days
another was a viral disease listed up
here on the star and that one that's
called high crp2 we now know is a viral
infection
and what's very interesting and very
important was there was a time when i
was asymptomatic this one here
called high crp1 with the circle
i also so i was clearly ill because i
had this high biomarker
but actually was did not have symptoms
and every single time my smart watch
told me i had high heart rate or high
skin temperature or combination of both
so that prompted us to write an
algorithm called change of heart
that lets you tell you when you're
getting ill by this change in heart rate
change from your baseline you can see it
jump
up and it turns out it operates in
advance of symptoms
so you can't tell well here but uh off
to the right
um the top four slides are me that's
what's called a delta plot you can see
change from base base heart rate it
jumps up every single time
that i was ill and it jumped up and
advance the symptoms and not only worked
on me this algorithm worked on
three other people one of whom got sick
twice so we had been actually improving
this algorithm and building a big
infrastructure you'll see in a minute to
be able to do this at scale
when along came the pandemic and as you
might imagine then we ramped us up
incredibly rapidly
so we have a irb approved study love to
have you joined we'll send you the link
uh in just a moment and what we did was
we partnered with leading companies like
fitbit
garmin we very quickly enrolled 6000 or
so people
who signed up for a study and we we
started by training
our algorithms on covet positive people
who were wearing a fitbit where we had
wearable data
at the time of infection and we had 32
of those we call these gold data sets
so these were we just took these and
wanted to see can we see this jump up in
heart rate
and it turns out the answer answer is
yes this is actually in fact
our very first person who wrote in our
study
this is the days here in one axis if you
look at that purple day day 48
that's when they were diagnosed with
covid the red day day 47
is when their symptoms first appeared
but if you look at the resting heart
rate in this top plot
you can see this jump up nine and a half
days before they had symptoms their
heart rate jumped up
and so this person was presumably ill
nine and a half days before
symptoms and was running around
spreading it had no idea
and we've written an alarming algorithm
i'll tell you about in a minute
that's the bottom plot that can see it
can detect us in in potentially real
time
and so as i say we had 32 data sets that
worked in 81
of the cases 26 of them all showed a
positive signal at
or before the time of infection and it
turns out there's a median of four days
prior to people having symptoms that we
can tell
this elevation and heart rate and in
fact again for a number of people is
even 10 days before symptoms so if
this works as an early early detection
system
uh it also turns out it's seven days
before diagnosis on average that's the
middle plot
and then on the right it's not specific
for covet if you're ill from other
things
you also see this jump up and resting
heart rate and that's a median of two
days and this makes sense because
for covet people tend to have a longer
asymptomatic period than for other
illnesses so
that's why covet has four days we
detected early versus two days for other
illnesses
so uh we've now as i say written a an
online detection system and this is
retrospective data meaning people we
already have data from but you can see
the very top plot
same thing this person we've set the
alarming in a way that it goes off
roughly every two months when people are
doing their normal thing but when a
coveted infection comes along it can
jump
up like the case on this top line this
one's i think about seven days early
the middle line the one all the way to
the right here is actually
um the coveted illness but there are
other bumps and
and we know other things can trigger the
alarm actually four out of seven people
get a holiday bump i don't know if
that's stress from in-laws or
alcohol or travel or other there are
things that can trigger the alarm that
aren't covet infections
uh and as i mentioned if you look at
panel c that this is a person
who had another illness there they
triggered the alarm as well
and even healthy people will have alarms
we don't know if those are asymptomatic
infections or stress periods what have
you we're actually collecting more data
on that
to better analyze this but nonetheless
it does work and it's pretty sensitive
in this initial study it was 67 percent
of the time we could pick up these
infections at or before
symptoms so we've now set up a a
collection system a whole infrastructure
for being able to pull in people's data
at scale we want to do this for tens of
millions of people
pull in their data and then we can
display back their wearable and other
data
actually on a very nice dashboard and a
very different time resolutions you can
look at whatever scale you like
and we've now rolled out the second
phase of the study where we're alarming
people
in real time we have 3 000 people signed
up you'll see in a minute
and it does work this is actually i
think our first case
is a case where it's set up at a daily
resolution
but this person had a an alert go off
basically a day before they had the
symptoms shown here
and that was a day that before they were
diagnosed and tested positive
so again we can pick up these alarms
early
and so far we as i say we have 2 700
people enrolled
63 of them have turned positive while
wearing the device we only just started
the study
at the beginning of december and uh 44
of them
were 70 percent received a positive
alert
prior to some information so we think
this could be a very very powerful
approach and again it's scalable to
millions of people
right now and smart watches themselves
aren't that expensive even a cheap one
for a hundred bucks
can do what i'm showing you and so we
again think these sensors could be super
powerful
uh since we first published our study
along with
a group from scripps um shown at the
bottom also with the fitbit other
studies come
out uh so this works for a group show
this for aura ring another group has
just put a
paper online not yet reviewed for apple
watch and we have it working for apple
watch as well in fact our latest study
uh that the one we're running now we'll
let you detect this with
uh fitbit apple watch garmin uh
basically any device
you should sign up okay so the other
area obviously that's
hugely important for managing this
pandemic is vaccination so i'll tell you
a little bit about what's going on there
so you probably know there's a lot of
different vaccination strategies out
there
uh there are at least four major types
so there's one with
mrna adenovirus those are the ones i'll
talk about a minute so this is a common
cold virus suit called adenovirus
different kind of cold
uh virus and then there are other
strategies as well that are mostly being
used in other countries
not so much in the us with the exception
of this novo vax one
it's in trials right now that's using a
portion of the spike protein
as an immune imaging so i'm going to
start by telling you about the mrna
vaccine what that's all about
so this study really starts about 30
years ago it turns out that
you know 30 years ago somebody had the
crazy idea two groups did of
just sticking dna right into somebody's
muscle injecting it straight in
and it turns out that makes antibodies
that was um
quite impressive at the time and so
um and that comes out of basic research
that people were
were doing then i think it was 2005 or
so the structure
of the chronovirus protein got solved
and then another key breakthrough is
actually being able
to make a stable form of the protein if
you're going to vaccinate it yet you
need a stable form of the protein so
your antibodies can recognize that
neutralize it
and that was set up by another uh group
as well so there's been a series of
important scientific
um advances that have let this
vaccination this mrna vaccination work
and so the way it works now is that you
can take
the spike gene if you will it actually
you make a modified mrna version so
mrnas are actually the information
transfer from genes
and they actually will code for proteins
so what you can do is and this is what
both moderna and the pfizer
vaccines are doing they make mrna copies
if you will from the gene
and then those get encapsulated into a
lipid
little lipid particles and those get
basically get injected right into your
muscle in fact
just on sunday i had mine injected into
my
my right arm and what will happen then
is those
those mrnas will start producing spike
protein
and you'll make antibodies to those and
those will be protective and that's the
general scheme for how this works
now one thing i want to let people know
some people sometimes
ask oh am i modifying my dna the answer
is no this is mrna it's not you're
going into your dna at all this is uh
you know sitting in your cells it's
producing protein so don't worry you're
not genetically modifying yourself if
you get this vaccine
okay and so it actually seems to be
incredibly protective you've seen the
reports it's at least 95
protective you get two shots and it
works
really really well probably better than
i think anybody anticipated
and it's also pretty remarkable if
you're thinking about because this whole
thing
was all pulled off in less than a year
which is probably
it certainly is a world's record from
start to
an approved vaccine the other vaccine
that's out there
comes from it's called the oxford
astrozenica vaccine
so there were some researchers in oxford
who were trying to make a vaccine to
also another nasty coronavirus called
mers that wasn't quite as rapidly
spreading
but it's pretty serious it does kill
people and so
um what they were doing is they took an
adenovirus from a chimpanzee so it's a
again antiviruses are common colds you
do get them
they use the form from a chimpanzee
thought would be a
little bit less problematic for humans
so that was the one they were using in
is a replicating virus that they use
what they do it's the same kind of idea
you take the spike
gene if you will you insert it into the
viral
dna in that case and then you use the
virus to actually stick into people's
arms and infect people
uh and and again this virus then will be
making the coronavirus
protein and then you'll go ahead and
start making antibodies against that
protein
and that gives you protective effects
and this vaccine also seems to work
pretty well
and certainly from true doses people
seem to be in good shape
and then there's another one that's
about to emerge uh they're waiting for
approval i
think it's expected any moment from
johnson johnson
what's special about this this is also
an endovirus
kind of vaccine where again you use the
spike protein they all use the spike
protein the surface protein
uh that they basically produce and then
again
people you make antibodies that what's
special about the johnson johnson it was
set up to just be a single dose vaccine
so far it seems to be about 70 effective
maybe not as good as the others
so here are the pros and cons the mrna
vaccines are special because they're not
immunogenic they're just sticking
this rna inside you directly into your
muscle with
the you do use lipids one minuses so
mrna is not so stable so you have to
store it cold one of them you actually
keep it a very deep freezer called a
minus 80. the other one
you can store in a regular freezer you
can pull them out we
have them refrigerated for a little bit
before you use them but you can't
they're not stable forever in the fridge
and you basically
need two doses of these the astrazeneca
oxford one
it's very effective similar to this one
very stable people do worry some people
do have strong reactions to viruses and
so
that may not be so good for them it does
require two doses
and then johnson and john said as far as
i can tell the main advantage it's a
single dose
it's not clear that it's as effect it's
as effective yet
as astrazeneca or the mrna ones uh
that's a mistake there sorry about that
okay so in summary what i've told you
about is that
our information about viruses has just
absolutely skyrocketed
thanks to this pandemic we're in and
uh now people to be honest take viral
infections a lot more seriously than
they used to
i think uh don't this virus is here to
stay so we are going to have to keep our
guard up
as to how to come up with newer newer
technologies for detecting it
and protecting ourselves from it and we
also have to worry about future
pandemics as well from other viruses
uh but there are um incredible people
out there working on new methods for
detecting and and these uh viral
infections
at a very early time so you can actually
you know potentially
self-isolate and not affect others and
our ability to make vaccines and i
didn't talk about it but some of the
therapeutics that are out there
has just been absolutely incredible and
so these are going to be important tools
for being able to better keep ourselves
healthy
and and manage uh infections when they
do occur
i do want to acknowledge the members of
my team i have an amazing group of
people working on the wearables project
and i won't have time to go through them
all but thanks to their very hard work
we've actually been able to get this our
study out there
and i would like again all of you to
sign up it'd be fantastic if you would
do so we'd be able to collect more data
and um we hope that this will be an
important strategy
for being able to defend ourselves
against not only this coronaviruses but
infections in the future so thanks again
for having me here thank you
thank you so much for taking the time to
share your presentation with us
so thank you for sharing your questions
with us
um i'll begin with the first question
the first question is are the rapid
tests
as effective as the test that takes 72
hours to receive results
yeah the pcr hopefully you can hear me
fine
the pcr tests are actually more accurate
than the antigen test
and most of the rapid tests of the
antigen test so they're not
quite as accurate but um but they are
very convenient and they're also cheaper
so you can run them more often so some
people
think that maybe the way to go is to get
everybody tested
every few days with these these rapid
tests
even if they're not as accurate because
you'll get tested more frequently
than those where you simply use those
pcr tests which are more expensive
probably a little less convenient so
that's the trade-off
and people are working obviously i'm
making them more and more accurate but
it it has to do with the technology as
to why they are the way they are
great question though our next question
is
can the mrna get into the nucleus with
reverse
transcriptase um
i'm not aware of any evidence of that it
seems like that would be a pretty low
probability we're
not putting reverse transcriptase in
these vaccines so
um it would not be likely
so you don't i don't think that you're
going to wind up modifying your your dna
with these
mrna vaccines
okay and the next question would be how
would you
comment on the differences in terms of
efficacy between other vaccines for
instance the flu
and coven yeah the covered ones seem to
be
so far much much more effective and
that's because
uh flu virus really mutates itself much
much more rapidly than
than coronavirus which does mutate some
and so it's generally thought that the
few in any given season the flu vaccines
are
probably anywhere from 30 to 70 percent
effective and
i think everyone was a standard these
mrna and so far it looks like the
astrazeneca ones are really quite
effective the mrna ones the data are
pretty good
they seem to be greater than 95
effective and that's
really amazing uh much much better than
any flu vaccines
and is the mrna vaccine better than the
inactive vaccine for covet 19
uh i think the head-to-head studies will
still have to come out
they weren't done exactly the same way
which makes it a little bit tricky i
think astrazeneca is hoping it's as
effective as the mrna ones
uh it has to do with iran there's at a
lower dose and a higher dose
and so in head head-to-head comparisons
it may not be
but it may not be quite as good but they
didn't do it exactly in head to head
that's the problem i didn't say that
right
so it's not as clear and so far the the
johnson johnson one from the data that
i've seen
seems to be less effective but it is
single dose so that's the trade-off
it's a great question though
okay for our next question for covid19
vaccines
can they still protect people if the
virus mutates a lot
and how can we say a vaccine is
efficient
like the pfizer bioentech covin 19
vaccine was 95
effective and others were 75 50 percent
effective
is it measured by how many people have
antibodies after the injection
yeah it's more measured by how effective
they are
neutralizing in in in the long term it's
actually
ability to block spreading um so they
certainly
don't block the infection per se but
they do
seem to to at least protect people and
one
report i've seen recently is that so far
from the first
75 000 people that have been vaccinated
that
actually got covered there's evidence
that they were exposed to kevin 19
uh not a single person has been killed
so they do seem to really be helping
people
in this case now some fraction of them
obviously do
not get totally protected and 95
percent's not the same as a hundred
so it is escaping in some cases back to
your original question how do we protect
ourselves as the virus is mutating
that is a serious concern all of us
worry about that
the strains that will emerge will be the
ones that
you know aren't protected against and
those will be the ones that will start
spreading again
one of the nice things about these
technologies is it's fairly easy to swap
out
a new strain that emerges from an
existing strain the problem is you have
to run these long trials to show
safety and such and that can slow things
down
but nonetheless it's still very powerful
to be able to quickly swap out
a new variant mrna for example than the
old one so
we'll try it's a bit of a you know cat
mouse game
that the virus is trying to get you know
further out there and spread and
we are trying to protect ourselves and
so there
there will be a battle going on for a
while so but the hope is
at least the the advantage by the way of
having a larger
part of the spike protein used is that
you don't just make antibodies against
one part you usually make it against
several parts so even if one part
mutates you'll get some protection as
the hope
from antibodies against other parts and
so
the hope is that at least it'll help and
that
may be the difference between you know
you surviving one of these infections
and not surviving
if you have some protective antibodies
and the next question is i read that the
sars
cov2 can be detected in feces is
detection from household wastewater
for sars kov2 and other viruses feasible
or
is it in the works yeah it's a great
question and the answer is
a number of groups are looking at that
you can do it in fact people are talking
about going into
sewage plants as a way to detect what
variants are out there and how frequent
they are and where they are so it may
turn out to be
a great way to measure the population
spread
of this virus so it turns out that's
true of a lot of colds they wind up in
the feces
okay we have a we have a lot of vaccine
questions
um the next one is if the j and j
vaccines were to have a booster shot a
second shot would the results be even
more effective than the pfizer and
moderna vaccines
yeah it hasn't been done it was the
trial wasn't set up that way to my
knowledge
at least not in the first part so we
don't know the answer to that i think
most scientists would expect that to be
the case
that a booster shot would be helpful but
that has not been done
great question
okay and then this one um refers to your
wearable
study uh what's the false positive rate
the alarm but no covid
yeah it depends how you set the alarm we
set it so it goes off every two months
so there's a little bit of a trick here
you can actually maximize the
sensitivity
so the alarm goes off every day and then
it'll go off very early in an infection
or you can dumb it way down but then you
you take the risk that you're waiting
longer before the alarm goes off so we
decided that
roughly once every two months is the
right sensitivity so
we think so far like i say in seventy
percent of the cases we can see
uh we can detect infections and people
who've had cobot so
uh that is a trade-off and and but i
don't think it's very hard to
contextualize what's going on so
for example we do know alcohol will
trigger the alarm and not if you just
have a few drinks
for dinner that won't do it but if you
really tie one on
and you're hungover for the next day you
actually might trigger the alarm or
if you run a marathon your heart rate
stays high for a few days and that might
also trigger the alarm
so you do have to contextualize it if
you've been doing something unusual
i'd say don't worry about it but if
you're just sitting around you know
listening to a webinar like this one and
suddenly your heart rate's running high
for you know 12 hours and your alarm
goes off
um something's up you're either very
stressed you're ill
something's not right so uh so that part
you'll have to contextualize
and i'll also point out by the way that
we don't know the difference what we're
not sure yet
we just know for example an alarm goes
off if you are infected it could be due
to cove but it could be due to other
viruses as well we're not there
so we are trying to bring in other kinds
of information right now we built the
whole thing around wrestling heart rate
because that's what we can get the data
for
uh and steps is incorporated in there as
well a little bit of sleep
but we know there's other things that
will help us a lot like skin temperature
respiration rate so as we bring in more
of these these
other kinds of physiological
measurements which you can get from a
smart watch
we hope to get more specific and also
maybe we'll be able to tell the
difference between a covet versus
another infection i'm pretty sure we can
tell the difference between a bacterial
infection
versus a viral infection we know that
from actually the lyme case
the time i got lyme disease
and regarding wearables wearable
technology seems to give us an amazing
amount of data
however what behavior changes would you
suggest people who test positive adopt
outside of isolating from others wearing
mass etc in other words
how do you see us using the information
that our wearable technologies capture
yeah just the way you described
obviously
we're not approved for this yet but what
you you know would think you would do
ultimately is that if you got a positive
signal you would self-isolate
uh when we have a at-home test she might
do a follow-up test and just see if you
are positive or
you know go to a physician if you start
feeling wor
worse so those are the possibilities
it's not unlike your car if you think
about it we have dashboards on our car
they're incredibly valuable they tell us
we're running low on gas
the engine light goes off you don't just
keep driving around when your engine
light's going off or maybe some people
do it but then their car gets trashed
so i think what you want to do is when
these alarms go off
you you use that information to better
guide what to do next and that's how we
see wearable devices they're really the
they along with your your smartphone are
really the dashboards
if you will for your health and by the
way i'm a true believer in this i'm
wearing i don't know if you can see but
i'm wearing four
smart watches right now so we're always
testing the different devices
often wear a ring but i lost it so so
anyway i do think these will be very
very powerful health monitors of the
future
just like you would drive your car
without a dashboard
i don't see why people you know run
around and
ignore their health without without a
sensor that could help them
um do you have a published
dataset and is it available online
it is so feel free to go to our paper
uh we're actually probably the only
group that's sharing data out there
there are now several studies that are
either submitted
a few of them are published and it's
just impossible to get the data it's a
real
uh pet peeve of mine that people don't
share their data well so anyway we do
have our data online go to our paper
or if you have any issues email me and
i'll put you in touch with the right
person
and you can get access to that data we
do anonymize it
uh meaning we'll shift the days and
things like that so
um but otherwise it's available for you
to use
i'm sure some of you can build better
algorithms than us
we do have pretty sophisticated people
on the project though
okay um and is there any evidence on the
duration of immunity provided by any of
the vaccines that you've talked about
today
great question and the answer is that's
been closely monitored so
i don't think people know how you know
protected they will be a year after
they're vaccinated
six months and so on so that's being
followed pretty close we do know the
antibodies persist for a while
and is it enough to give protection
against the next viral infection it may
depend on the dose
meaning a super high dose may overcome
any low level
antibodies you have running around but
low level doses may be perfectly managed
so
so this is the sort of thing people are
following very carefully
and so you know i wish i had a more
definitive answer for you but
it's the the way the way it is i think
the encouraging part is again that
people who have been vaccinated
so far no one has died to my knowledge
and so that really is an encouraging
sign
that they are being protective at some
level but we'll have to see how long
that lasts great and maybe we'll need
booster shots every you know
nine months or every two years it's not
clear yet
okay and why um
is there a need for two doses in the
mrna vaccines
yeah now the mrna vaccines don't have
what's called an
agilent that kind of promotes your
immune response they clearly work a lot
of people do get sore arms i sure did
when i got my vaccine so they they do
have some effect
but they don't they're not um set up
with a
with this agilent which gives a really
strong first response
and so it's thought that the two doses
will actually give a better protective
the first dose triggers of the the
immune response and the next one really
gives you a much stronger boost if you
will
and and so that's one of the arguments
used
great question and then
why are spike genes the target of all of
the vaccines
yeah because they're on the surface
they're the things that
the spike protein recognizes the
receptor on our cells this
receptor happens to be called ace2 and
if you can block that interaction or
block
yeah just get in the way of it then the
virus can't really
enter the cell so so that's very
very important for the immunity to be to
be able to hit the outside of the virus
so it really can't get in once it gets
in it's off and running
and then what would you say to people
who tell you i'll not get vaccinated
because nobody knows enough about the
vaccine
or they make claims that people may
become infertile
etc how would you convince them
well i'd say look at the data so far
certainly the short-term effects look
pretty
fine millions of people have been
vaccinated uh
the number of deaths one could argue
about most people would say it's zero
some people say well maybe there's a few
we're telling many millions of people
have now been vaccinated
and look how many people have died when
they've gotten the chronovirus so that
number is very large it's probably on
the order of at least one percent
uh depends what the a the asymptomatic
number is
but uh weighing the odds i'd say you're
much much better
getting vaccinated than getting a
coronavirus infection
and do you believe that covid vaccine uh
that you'll require a new vaccine every
year like a flu shot for instance
i think we're gonna have to see yeah
whether
you know if new emerging strains come it
will make sense to
morph the vaccine strategies that we're
using i think the
overall strategy will be the same but
the actual sequences that people use
will probably get altered as well um
and so it's possible it's possible
okay and do you see a development of uh
mrna
vaccine for uh a flu the flu for
instance
it's possible yeah i i think that's in
fact quite
likely i think this is going to be a
general strategy and
certainly these companies are all
working on this so
it could become a whole new strategy and
again most people like the a
concept because it's a little bit
cleaner than putting a virus
into people even if it's a virus that
causes common cold
a lot of people like you it's probably
better not to have a virus at all so
there's a good chance that this will
become the future
of vaccination
and so the mechanism of vaccines
encourages the immune system to act
against the virus
if this is true what is the risk that
the immune system will be exacerbated in
such a way that it will also react
fighting the body's own cells
yeah i think people do worry about this
to what extent do
viruses in general or vaccines trigger
autoimmune disease certainly you know
historically obviously the the things
they put in kids those are those are
very very low
uh is it zero i don't think we know the
answer yet
but i don't think there's any reason to
think that the vaccine will be worse
for causing an autoimmune disease and
the viral infection itself
so i think these are things people worry
about it's it's very clear
that coven 19 does have these long
hauling effects so to speak uh that is
to say that there
are effects that seem to last for months
and it's not
clear what they're due to so i think
people are very very concerned
and trying to follow what's going on
there doesn't mean they're autoimmune by
the way there could be other effects
that are caused as well
but these are the things people do worry
about again i don't think there's any
reason to think that the
the vaccination would be worse than the
viral infection again speaking for
myself
um i personally think it's a lot better
to get a vaccine
and then a viral infection and in fact
that's why i got the vaccine i think
pretty much everybody will tell you the
same thing and especially if you're at
risk for certain things i think
you're really putting yourself on the
line if you don't get vaccinated
and in light of potential restrictions
to only give one dose to many versus two
doses to a few
what are the pros and cons about mixing
vaccines for instance moderna for the
first dose and
astrazeneca for the second dose that's a
great question and
nobody's done that because uh it's not
set up that way the trials aren't but
i think that could be a very powerful
strategy if you think about it
uh but we'll have to see and i don't
know how long it'll take to run trials
like that but
um i personally like that concept
uh and but we'll have to see um
we just don't know it's as you can tell
it's still very early days the first
vaccines just got approved in december
so these are all great questions that we
just don't know the answer to
right and um the next question is
is my phd uh being used to
track recovery from covid19 or other
viral illnesses and are there any
or have there been any interesting
outcomes
yeah we we're doing that now we'd love
you to sign up and
and cl we want to collect your data it's
very very clear we can see
heart rate patterns persist well after
the infection so we think there are
lingering effects from people have
coconut and all but in a subset of
people
and so we are trying to follow exactly
what you just said
so we would like to collect that
information we we have some other
studies going on where we're actually
doing what we call micro sampling
sampling small droplets of blood from
people so we can
see what these long-term effects are and
so we do want to collect that
information and better understand
what is going on and maybe that will
help us suggest
treatments also maybe predict early on
who's going to have a long-term effect
by their initial signals they get
so you can imagine a case with a smart
watch where certain signals go off of a
certain type
maybe someone has a very strange heart
rate variability for example or other
things
and that predicts severity or long-term
effects
of a coveted infection and that could
ultimately be powerful for treating such
people uh and and certainly identifying
them
so great questions though
so it looks like we have time for a
couple more questions um the next
question
is um that you mentioned uh mrna
vaccines
um that they do not modify genes as mrna
only produces more proteins
the question is is there any evidence or
a biomolecular knowledge that could
confirm that there is no
indirect way that it could affect dna
either short or long
term uh i'm not aware of any so
um yeah i think it's very unlikely
um that it itself will affect dna now
you may be raising an issue a general
issue which is
i not so clear we have evidence for
example you may not know i'm type 2
diabetic
and it actually came about because of
the viral infection in fact it's the
first time someone associated
a viral infection with type 2 diabetes i
got it right after a nasty
in that case respiratory syncytial virus
that's why i followed this field fairly
closely in fact
and it turns out that actually it didn't
uh you know it didn't modify my dna i
don't think
but there's something called epigenetics
where your dna can get chemically
modified
and it actually turns out that um my dna
did in fact my
immune cells were just you know shifted
a little bit
in in their chemical modification
epigenetic change
and we think that's what triggered my
type 2 diabetes
uh it's it's very correlated with that
it's hard to prove but it's very
correlated
so it is possible going back to your
point that there is
uh um some long-term effects that are
due to indirect
uh aspects of the viral infection it's
probably not the mrna itself though
inserting into your dna
which i know is what a lot of people are
concerned about that seems
you know that's not your biggest concern
okay and what if um we don't get the
second vaccine
in three or four weeks or even eight
weeks how effective will the second dose
then be
i don't think we know the answer to that
i would recommend you get your second
dose
[Music]
okay um
and for the wearable study how do you
account for exercise
uh yeah we i i didn't emphasize this but
it's resting heart rate so we take the
periods while you're not
exercising in fact we put we found the
optimal
window as is 10 minutes after moving
is when we take this information so you
not only have to stop moving but we
won't
take your heart rate for the next 10
minutes
so that turns out to be a reasonably
accurate measurement
of resting heart rate and so then you
can really see these shifts up
and one thing i want to emphasize is we
all have very different resting
excuse me resting heart rates and so um
this is why this works we can measure
your resting heart rate really quite
accurately 24 7 and when
you do see a viral infection or other
kinds of stress you will see that shift
it's only seven beats a minute
it's not a huge number but that's very
very easy to
to measure when you're taking hundreds
of thousands of measurements on
on a person a day you even small amounts
when you measure them over time you can
pick it up with very high confidence
great and last question um
if you have autoimmune conditions
and are on immunosuppressants will the
copic vaccine be effective for you
you should see your doctor um i have my
own thoughts here but it depends on the
nature of your illness and i
so i think you should talk to your
physician about this
and they will also devise a strategy
with you which vaccine i would hope they
would which vaccine is best
i have my own thoughts but i'm not a
physician so you're better off talking
to your own physician
all right thank you very much we're
getting close to the end of our webinar
so we'll need to wrap
up now um thank you dr
snyder if you'd like to learn more from
dr snyder and the rest of the genetics
faculty we encourage you to join our
stanford genetics and genomic
certificate program
um you'll have more than 90 hours of
content to learn from them
as well as access to videos and
exercises to sharpen your skills
a link to this recording will be emailed
to you soon so feel free to revisit this
content
once again thank you for joining us
today we hope you have a great week and
we hope to see you again in future
sessions